cette décision de vouloir absolument
restreindre les mouvements de facilité
les interpellations cerbitraires
soient-elles ça nous révèle quoi
finalement une perte de contrôle
alors oui non la première chose c'est
l'affirmation justement du contrôle et
de la possession sur ces quatre
territoires d'honnête louhansd Origins
bon la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement ce que vous dites
c'est-à-dire probablement le sentiment
de la part du pouvoir russe que tout ne
va pas comme sur des roulettes c'est à
dire qu'effectivement des gens qui
peuvent profiter encore d'une relative
liberté et bien se réunissent s'associe
pas forcément que des Ukrainiens des
Russes aussi qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec le tournant que que prennent les
choses donc il y a cette volonté de
contrôler Julien la rappeler c'est une
c'est une remise si vous voulez sous la
tutelle militaire de tout ce qui est de
l'ordre des activités à la fois
administratives mais aussi civiques donc
quand on a vu ça est-ce que ça signifie
que Poutine finalement dégaine ces
dernières cartouches
c'est un peu rapide on peut penser oui
qu'il y a ce souci chez lui mais en même
temps vous voyez bien qu'il veut avancer
de manière un peu graduelle ou graduée
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas la
mobilisation générale parce que là il
aurait des soucis autrement plus
importants mais c'est regarder vous en
Occident voilà ce que je peux faire
c'est monter d'un cran et si la
mobilisation générale découlée de cette
loi martiale ça voudrait dire que je
veux me battre encore vous voyez c'est
une réponse alors évidemment vous allez
me dire et vous auriez raison que les
esprits faibles qui sont en Occident ou
ailleurs diront mais voilà c'est
maintenant qu'il faut négocier à tout
prix et profiter simplement justement
Poutine se dit on les esprits les plus
éclairés alors ça c'est une question de
point de vue et de goût mais
aboutit appelle à cette sorte de
gradation pour justement faire
comprendre qu'il n'a pas tout claqué
pour l'instant qu'il n'a pas tout
utilisé alors donc voilà c'est ça c'est
ça le jeu c'est réaffirmer la possession
sur ses territoires qui ne sont pas
russes et surtout moi je pense à cette à
cette idée qui est de contrôler mieux
parce que au fond si tout était clair
pour Poutine y aurait les Ukrainiens les
mauvais d'un côté et les Russes qui sont
bons et je crois qu'on a vu depuis le
début de ce conflit que les lignes sont
plus compliquées que ça et que tout ce
qui est par exemple russophone ou même
qui se reconnaît comme russe n'est pas
favorable à Poutine ils n'empêche le
président Poutine tous les cas alors
tout dépend de l'analyse que l'on fait
mais peut-être faut-il y voir en début
de fragilisation il en appelle au
soutien des Iraniens ou en tout cas des
armes iraniennes le 6 octobre dernier un
accord a même été passé avec le un haut
responsable du régime iranien des drones
des missiles ont été envoyés sur
plusieurs grandes villes il se passe
quoi
deux choses
les missiles sur les grandes villes ça
correspond sur les centres énergétiques
sur l'infrastructure énergétique et sur
les grandes villes ça correspond à ce
que l'extrême droite russe réclame alors
on a déjà parlé cette extrême droite
elle est protéiforme enfin grosso modo
c'est frappons les centres énergétiques
pour que les Ukrainiens soient dans le
noir dans l'obscurité et qu'il crève de
froid ça c'est très clair et la deuxième
chose c'est acheter à l'Iran mais ça
c'est vrai que ça révèle des choses
acheter à l'Iran des missiles qui sont
pas vraiment d'une précision
extraordinaire donc ils sont là pour
terroriser si vous voulez il n'y a pas
si la Russie voulait uniquement cibler
les centres énergétiques il faudrait des
instruments un peu plus précis et puis
en même temps ça veut dire qu'elle n'a
plus les moyens d'en fabriquer elle-même
quelle est tacourt sur des matériaux
extrêmement basiques et qu'elle doit
demander à l'Iran de lui vendre c'est ce
type de choses alors du côté iranien ça
a une simple ça a un profit très c'est
de dire à l'Occident qui est embarqué
aussi dans une critique non seulement du
nucléaire iranien mais aussi de
l'affaire du voile et des femmes qui se
sont en train de se libérer c'est de
dire à l'Occident si vous nous embêtez
avec cette chose là on ira encore plus
loin côté missile voilà voilà la
configuration et cette situation qui
incite certains encore une fois à
vouloir profiter de ce qu'est une
accalmie pour réclamer des négociations
mais on voit bien que c'est pas tout à
fait une chose qui est en tout cas qui
n'est pas évidente en ce moment merci
Gauthier merci pour cette analyse